now what does the federal reserve system
actually do so many people say you know
I see this and the Federal Reserve I
don't know what the Federal Reserve Bank
does and why is it it 60 CE grow it does
several things one of the benign things
it does and in some ways efficiently and
that is they exchange checks you know
they're an exchange Bureau but that
could be done very easily privately the
real even what they do is they create
money and credit if the federal
government runs up a debt and they tend
to have a habit of doing this you know
Congress is you know run by Republicans
and Democrats say they all spend money
they run up the debt of course they when
they spend they have to tax us if they
can't tax enough then they have to
borrow and if they can't borrow enough
then they have one other option they can
tax and borrow inflate inflate the most
important thing to remember is inflating
is not the prices and the prices go up
after the money is inflated and the
money loses its value so the Fed is
designed to accommodate the politician
in a very secretive manner the
politicians spend the money because the
special interest comes like we want this
we want this the politician gets
reelected so he's rewarded and the tax
becomes an indirect tax instead of going
directly to the people what we what the
Federal Reserve does is they can take a
Treasury bill except the Treasury bill
which now is just a mirror computer
entry they accept the Treasury bill of
ten billion dollars and then give
Treasury ten billion dollars in their
checking account where did the Federal
Reserve get the money right out of thin
air right from heaven they create the
money they put it in the checking
account in this her suri spends it and
then that means that the people who got
that money immediately get to spend it
it has value but as it circulates in the
economy the value of the purchasing
power of the money goes down and you
have prices going up the the bad part
about this is not everybody suffers
equally if the money supply went up ten
percent and every one of us had to cost
of living go up identities ten percent
it would be nearly the great harm but
because of the system it's designed
literally the benefit the politicians
and the bankers and big corporation of
those who get the money they get the
money they get the benefit in
somebody else in a year or two or three
suffers the consequences we read about
the Federal Reserve as a banker's bank
and we see them that they raise the
discount rate or they increase the money
supply what all these things mean well
the bankers Bank means literally that
the bankers are required to put their
deposits in the Federal Reserve System
and they're accountable the Federal
Reserve System these have to send in the
reports the preserve the Federal Reserve
has all these regulations and rules so
they control the whole entire banking
system if in the in their efforts to
fine tune although they literally
destroy the money they don't want to
destroy the money they want to control
things so when inflation gets perking
along they're aware the same economic
thoughts that I'm aware of and they know
that if they're not a little bit
cautious about this they could have you
know runaway inflation so they tend to
back off but they benefit from the
backing off that means they tighten the
credit raise the interest rates and
cause a recession and they do it in the
name of saving the economy which they
have to or the currency gets out of
control but if they know it's coming
then they benefit on a two then they
benefit they know then to be in cashion
or and I interest rates in the banks
benefit by it so they whether the
economy's going up or down if they are
designing the policy they can they can
catch the swing so it's the inside
information that they have but they
didn't give the recession's which are
literally the results of the inflation
the system would crumble much faster but
our argument as hard money people is
that in spite of their arrogance to
think that they can keep this going
forever and as powerful as they are the
market is more powerful see for decades
they kept the gold price at thirty-five
dollars an ounce I said we will regulate
the price of gold but they kept printing
the money that market finally broke down
the price of gold well the marketplace
will finally win out and the people will
wake up and say it's all paper it's all
a scam and that's when there's chaos and
that's when the painters realize they're
getting out of control and that's when
the connection of the bankers to the
politicians is critical because then
power is threatened
so that's when they then they come down
with political controls of our lives
that's why the emergency powers are
already written the president can
declare an emergency and take over the
industries and take over our lives and
confiscate to go and that's why we
should be concerned we should be
concerned for you know our prosperity
you know our standard of living and all
but our greatest concern on to be that
when these crises come in the market
disrupts this political system in this
monetary system then we're threatened by
political power taking away more of our
personal liberties this the FEMA
regulations of your toy the pills are
done under the FEMA the emergency powers
and it came up even in the Contra
hearings that they were emergency powers
written a matter of fact that great hero
Oliver North was in participating in
designing some of these to literally if
necessary suspend the Constitution these
are the kind of things are timing I
don't know if you reset up the
concentration camps so this was brought
up at the FEMA in the iran-contra
hearings remember immediately suppressed
that and they say this is something we
can't discuss that shows very good
people aren't a lot of know by this and
that's why whoo-hoo protected this
information who protected all over North
the head Democrat which goes to show you
the power structure is the same John you
made a big study of the history of the
Federal Reserve how did it come about
what's murky story and I think that
maybe 1913 not to be the year they went
down and infamy in American history
because not only did we get just barely
in 1913 the Federal Reserve we also got
the income tax in the very same year and
those two things have work to our didn't
really been a very negative thing in our
society our economy ever since that time
but it was a very secretive thing it
really goes back to the bankers getting
in a sealed railway car and sneaking off
to Jekyll Island Georgia and it was a
very secret meeting in fact they call it
the first name club they only call each
other by their first name so that even
people who work there as waiters and
servants and so forth later couldn't
identify for sure who had even
participated
that meeting was only about four or five
people it was about ten i believe in or
twelve and that group of people
literally laid the basis for what became
the federal reserve basically
Rockefeller Morgan people those that
group you probably know something in
that area of house there's in lot there
and the Woodrow Wilson people were there
although this occurred I believe in
nineteen ten or so when they match up a
lot of house that's right there's a
couple of years later a time it got
planned it was finally passed in
nineteen thirty it was kind of sneaked
through Congress and Wilson actually
signed that into law the federal reserve
act like two days before Christmas and
when many of the senators and
congressmen of course with
transportation in 1913 Dean what it was
they had long since left the Nation
capital many of them but the ones that
they wanted to stay and vote did stay
and vote wilson signed the law two days
before Christmas and traditionally
hasn't that been a period where by
gentlemen's agreement the important
legislation is not enacted right around
the Christmas holiday it may be a
gentleman's agreement but that's
generally at the time and I was always
most vigilant because I realize that's
where most of garbage pass the most of
the more onerous you know in the last
day of the session is unbelievable
stacks and stacks of pieces of
legislation come in nobody reads
anything so the worst things happen a
particular time but it is supposed to be
that if the members aren't attending
that they wouldn't be doing these kind
of things but you're absolutely right
there was a very low attendance and and
it was it was an unusual year because
generally Congress didn't meet that late
in the year and I don't know whether
they were called back into session wepa
it was unusual for Congress back in
those days now it's very common to meet
all year round so back then they were
usually only in Section two or three
months of the year but here they were in
session in December very unusual year
and one of the most important pieces of
legislation certainly in our history
kind of just rushed through at the last
minute without anyone really paying that
much attention to it and I think is so
interesting there there were a lot of
people who weren't fooled a lot of the
congressman from the western part of the
United States even the South more
populous areas weren't fooled by what
was happening they recognize it as a
gravy train going to the bankers
so they naturally were opposed to it and
in reading book secret or federal
reserve I thought it was fascinating
that the bankers set up an organization
to complain about this federal reserve
act which was there they were secretly
would say secretly hatched up and they
were secretly trying to get past but
they complained that it was going to
kill him just so it would the people
that think that oh well we're going to
pass this and it will harness the banks
yet they were literally getting a
license to steal because that really
permitted this fractional reserve
banking system to occur where they can
pyramid their deposits loan out money
that they don't even have so it was a
tremendous benefit to the bankers
nothing of this that you'll find in
history books or books on government or
economic history the United States
nothing about how they're certainly not
teaching you in school not in history
classes hobby schools hopefully we will
see that it gets taught somewhere